Ukraine Russian forces have launched
some of the heaviest air attacks on the
capital and other major cities since the
War Began officials there say most of
the Russian missiles and drones were
shot down overnight more missiles were
fired at Kiev this morning Deborah padda
has more from Northeastern Ukraine
searchlights comb the night skies over
Kiev hunting for exploding drones on
Sunday swarms of the iranian-made
aircraft headed mainly for the capital
this video captures the moment one of
them was taken out
for over five hours the menacing sound
of Air Raid Sirens kiv claimed 58 out of
a staggering 59 drones were shot down
it's not just state-of-the-art high-tech
defense systems being deployed
ukrainians are quite happy to use good
old-fashioned technology like this
at an undisclosed military site we saw
troops testing powerful new searchlights
that helped locate those low-tech drones
so they can be targeted
but the arrival of the American-made
Patriot system this spring has enabled
the ukrainians to intercept more
powerful aerial threats Alexander Ruben
is Keith's Chief forensic investigator
he showed us a Hypersonic Russian kinjal
missile a weapon that Kremlin boasted
was Unstoppable
thanks to our American Partners we can
actually touch this missile he said it
sits in this graveyard of destroyed
Russian Munitions evidence for the
massive war crimes dossier he's helping
compile Reuben says Russia appears to be
targeting Ukraine's air defense network
as a counter-offensive draws close those
attacks have become more frequent
for CBS mornings Deborah patter heart
cave